entre deux voyages vers los angeles ou
new york orlan est de passage en
touraine
insaisissable l'artiste est une
véritable touche à tout je fais des
choses extrêmement diversifié je fais
des robots je m'intéresse à
l'intelligence artificielle je cultive
mes cellules mais je fais aussi des
sculptures en marbre de carrare et des
sculptures en 3d prennent thing orlan ne
fait pas dans le consensuel son art
navigue plutôt entre provocation et
polémiques j'essaye toujours de dire des
choses importantes pour notre société et
j'interroge des phénomènes de société et
j'essaye moi de nous faire réfléchir
ensemble deux de ses oeuvres sont
actuellement exposées au château du
rivau à les mre elle y donnait une
conférence mercredi à la rencontre du
public de quoi ravir la propriétaire de
la bâtisse fiers d'accueillir l'artiste
orlan d'abord c'est une histoire
d'amitié en et renier j'aime cette femme
je les admire une combattante elles
baissent jamais les bras continue
toujours or l'on a également sorti son
autobiographie écrite pendant le
confinement l'occasion de saisir un peu
mieux cet artiste hors norme